So it's one thing to say that our
project build successfully, but
how do we know that it works right?
The best answer that software
engineering has come up with for
this is to use a lot of
different kinds of tests.
Now testing is a hug subject and
we actually have a whole course on it,
but let's take a quick look at
some different kinds of tests.
Unit tests are tests the developers
write along side the application code.
Each test checks the behavior
of one specific unit of code,
like a function or class.
They're designed to be automated.
Developers will run them repeatedly
as part of the development process.
Regression test on the other hand,
get written as part of debugging and
troubleshooting.
Once you've fixed a bug, you want to
make sure that it doesn't come back due
to some future oversight or regression.
So you add a test that checks
specifically for that particular bug.
Like unit tests, regression tests
are automated and run frequently.
A smoke test is something that gets run
after the build, kind of a sanity check
to make sure the system basically works
before doing any more refined testing.
For instance, if our project is a web
server, we might just bring a server
instance up and fetch the home page
just to make sure it doesn't crash.
The term smoke test comes
from electrical engineering.
You can imagine plugging an appliance or
a machine in and
seeing if it catches fire, but
it also has an older meaning in plumbing
as a test for newly installed pipes.
Before putting water in a pipe, plumbers
would fill it with pressurized smoke to
see if the smoke leaked out anywhere.
A system integration task
is just a little bigger.
It's a test of the system
including not just our code, but
also the back-ends and dependencies and
data that our code makes use of.
You might often run it on
dedicated test machines.
Before we treat infrastructure as code,
we can spin up test instances as
VMs dynamically when we need to.
In doing that,
we'll test our deployment scripts too.
An automated acceptance test is
something that you'd write to verify
that a system or
feature does what the user wants it to.
Now it can't replace everything that
a human QA tester might do, but
there are testing frameworks
that let automate quite a lot.
Whole workflows, clicking buttons,
filling out data fields,
whatever a user might do in your app.
And then depending on your service,
you might have a manual QA step as
well before launch goes to production.
If that's the last step before launch,
the QA tester's approval can actually
tell the continuous deployment system
that it's okay to go
ahead with the roll out.
So there we have six different
kinds of testing, unit testing,
regression testing, smoke testing,
system integration testing,
automated and manual acceptance testing.
While we're talking about testing,
let's talk about bugs too.
Having a single, unified bug
tracking system can go a long way to
improving communication amongst teams.
If it's accessible to everyone in
the organization to report issues and
collaborate on fixing them,
then that's one less barrier
to getting real work done.